a friend of mine used to say you win
some and you lose some and I think that
is really true not only for language
learning but for anything else in life
hi my name is Luca from Lucca Don Pardo
comm and today I'm going to talk to you
about my biggest language failure in
Japanese when some people ask me the
somewhat arranging question how many
languages do you speak I often catch
myself replying that a speech 13
languages but the reason why I think
that I've been learning a 13 languages
would be a better and more honest reply
is that first you never stop learning
not even your own native language and
second as a matter of fact your language
arsenal changes with time because some
languages that you used to speak very
well before maybe you do not speak them
well anymore because you haven't been
practicing them now let's take Japanese
for example I started learning Japanese
some 10 years ago and truth be told I
did spend a lot of time on Japanese I
have as you can see here a lot of
resources that I used manga grammar
books etc etc you name it but even then
even after starting speaking Japanese
with my tutor and reading and listening
unfortunately I have never really gotten
to the point where I felt so confident
that I could handle the language in any
possible situation a lot of time has
gone by and I've started focusing more
and more on other languages and I've put
Japanese a little bit on the side and I
would say that technically I do not
speak in any more in the sense that it
would be very difficult for me to make a
video in Japanese now now if you think
about it the interesting thing is that
this has happened to other languages as
well unfortunately if you speak a bunch
of languages it's also very difficult to
maintain all the others and for example
Swedish and/or Mandarin Chinese are
languages that I do not practice any
more on a daily basis but the difference
is that for Mandarin Chinese or for
Swedish I've reached a level where I
have acquired a skill that is the skill
of speaking having conversations using
the language so I know that if I had to
make a video in Swedish or if I had to
make a video men
or if I have to have a conversation for
that matter I could go back to listening
reading and practicing a little bit and
that would go back very quickly well
with Japanese that would be much more
problematic because I guess that I've
never really developed this fluency or
this capacity of manipulating the
language as I want so first of all it's
a liberation for me to admit that
Japanese has been kind of a failure but
the most important part of the video is
to talk about the lessons I've learned
and the lessons that are going to be
useful for me if I start learning
Japanese again and for you if you decide
to learn Japanese or if you have failed
in any other language
so I've been doing some thinking and
some pondering and trying to understand
why I had failed with Japanese and here
are some of the reasons why I think I
have never reached the level I wanted to
reach I always say that one of the most
important steps when it comes to
starting learning a language is choosing
the right resource unfortunately in the
case of Japanese I stuck through the
very same resource that I use all the
time which is a Cemile but in this case
Asamoah was not what I expected
the sentences and the dialogues were too
complicated from the very beginning and
as a consequence of that at point number
two I applied my bi-directional method
but it did not work the way I expected
meaning that I was trying to translate
back and forth from Japanese into
Italian and from Italian to Japanese
things that were too complicated for my
mind to deal with from the very
beginning as a consequence of that and
that is the third point I started
thinking in a way that it was too
complicated I started filtering
everything through the Italian language
so let me give an example Japanese has a
very very different structure when it
comes to syntax that is the way you
arrange sentences in Italian for example
or in English if you want to say
something like I want to go to Tokyo
well in English you say I want to go to
Tokyo and Italian you say volure and
that at Tokyo it's exactly the same
structure subject verb particle and
destination Japanese though you would
say Tokyo nee Akita which means Tokyo
particle of movement I'm going to the
city want to go or to go once and this
is a very simple statement imagine if
you say something like I want to go to
Tokyo because I heard or I've heard that
it's a great city in Italian you would
say something very similar value and
Aria Tokyo per kilo centi Tokyo una
grande chi-town Abela cheetah but in
Japanese you would say Tokyo particle
great city
I've heard because Tokyo particle I want
to go I think so this gives you the idea
or an idea of the fact that if you
filter everything through your native
language it's gonna take you seconds to
think about a very simple sentence and
the longer the sentence the worstest
gets so a combination of the wrong
resource as semilla I don't think it was
the resource I had I should have chosen
the bi-directional translation applied
to very long and complicated and
uninteresting sentences caused me to
think and want to think in a way that
was too complicated from the very
beginning I never got rid of that so
every time that's when I moved to
conversations with my Japanese tutor
psycho
I just tried to speak but it took me 2 3
seconds for each sentence and in my head
my brain was fuming as a consequence of
that I was very discouraged from the
very beginning and despite a great
amount of time and books that I
dedicated that I used to Japanese I
never got rid of this complication /
complication and I never made my
communication smooth and to the point
which was quite discouraging so the
combination of the wrong material from
the very beginning the wrong approach
because I think the bi-directional
translation is great but not apply to a
Samoan that way and this tendency of
over complicating everything was was
kind of you know getting in the way but
I think that if I think about it there's
also a couple of other factors that
really made a difference and the first
is that I've never gone to Japan truth
be told
Japan is not exactly around the corner
so it's not that you you know gravity
can you go there but I think that if I
had gone to Japan if I had breathed the
Japanese air the Japanese culture the
way people talk the way they act the way
they speak the way they lived the way to
eat the way they drink I think that the
moment I eat I would have gotten back to
Italy I would have had
another great boost of motivation and
they've never done that and you can tell
yourself okay Japan is far I don't have
the money I don't have the time but I'm
pretty sure that there are a lot of
Japanese around in Europe be a tourists
or people live in Europe that I could
have gotten in contact with and I
haven't done that yes I have come into
contact with psycho
my Japanese tutor and we had great
conversations but it was always through
Skype I think that getting to know
people in real life and experiencing
life and circumstances with Japanese
would have made a great difference so
here you have a combination of the wrong
approach what you do by yourself but
also I think that in the case of in the
extreme case of languages that are
particularly difficult particularly
exotic you need some extra boost and
maybe I didn't have the courage maybe
didn't have the money I don't remember
at the time we meet I didn't have the
time or the energy to go to Japan or to
create a Japanese reality which I'm sure
would have made a great difference
I still remember in 2012 or 2013 that
after learning the language for a little
bit I really started thinking maybe
Japanese is not for me maybe Japanese is
gonna elude me for the rest of my life
Luca Colombo diello the guy who learns
all these languages and he's failing
miserably and learning Japanese just
can't get through his thick head and
then I started thinking about the
learning process I started reading a lot
of books about neuroplasticity and about
our capacity to learn pretty much
anything and I told myself nope that's
not because Japanese is not for you
that's not because your brain structure
is not is not good for learning this
kind of language there really believed
that the truth is that you have to when
you fail at something it's because you
probably use the wrong method and you
were not motivated enough for you or not
you you didn't have the right
circumstances so right now I know that
at some point in the future can be in
one year can be in a cup
years this depends on the number of
languages I'm gonna learn and the you
know life circumstances I will go back
to Japanese and I will reuse these
lessons in order to learn it properly
properly right now and you can do
exactly the same if you think that you
failed to learning a language because
for some reason you are not good enough
or because you're not motivated enough
remember that everything flows
everything changes the brain structure
you have today is not gonna be the brain
structure you're gonna have down the
line and whenever you fail or whatever
you think you made a mistake just use
these failures so called fader so called
mistakes to improve upon what you're
building because you can accomplish
anything I can accomplish anything you
can accomplish anything for any and in
any language so you might be wondering
okay look how you're gonna start
learning Japanese again what are you
gonna do differently than you did before
well for starters I'm not gonna use
ASIMO I'm going to find a resource that
has compelling content content that I
find interesting and possibly that is
relatively simple and third that is
comprehensible to me can be a bilingual
book it can be a book just in Japanese
but that has explanations in English or
any other language that I can understand
and then I'm going to when it comes to
speaking and producing the language I'm
gonna scale back and I'm going to make
sure that I communicate from the very
beginning with very simple messages
grabbing the example that I Eve was
illustrating before instead of trying to
say I want to go to Tokyo I want to go
to Japan I want to go to Osaka because
I've heard that just simplify go to the
bone and say I want to go to Japan I
heard the Tokyo is beautiful or just
Tokyo is beautiful Tokyo is great very
simple snippets of language because if
you communicate in simple
and that is what kids actually start
doing when they speak the language you
will simplify the thought process and
the language and your mind will not go
and resort this defense mechanism of
using the structures of your own native
language I'm pretty sure that this has
happened to you as well when you try to
speak a foreign language and you try to
sound refined and and educated you tend
to use words or sentences that are too
complicated and you end up trying to say
something that if you don't have the the
arsenal if you don't have the weapons
the linguistic weapons to convey then
you're just gonna get stuck that's
exactly what happened with Japanese so I
am pretty confident that I'm not gonna
make that mistake again and even if my
mind will tell you Luka my adults mind
will tell you Luka you will sound very
simple simple does not mean simplistic
Einstein used to say that simplicity is
beauty or beauty is simplicity so at
first I will accept and you have to
accept that it's important to speak with
in snippets in simple messages and later
down the line I'm going to learn to
connect these snippets or these messages
so I want to go to Japan and I like
Japanese I want to go to Osaka or Osaka
and then you will learn to put these
together I want to go to Japan that's
why I want to learn Japanese and so on
and so forth and if you learn the
connectors then you're going to build
the language better and you're gonna
sound more refined etc that's exactly
what Japanese kids have done they
haven't started with complicated
sentences they have started from the
base of course now that I know that I
can I know how to deal with input and I
know how to deal with output I would say
that that's not enough I think that the
fuel that is going to propel my Japanese
in the long run is actually falling in
love with the Japanese culture seeing
Japan I really want to go to Japan
that's why I'm thinking that
no matter when I'm going to learn
Japanese the moment I decide when I'm
gonna learn Japanese again we're gonna
start learning Japanese again I will pay
a visit to beautiful Japan so that when
I come back I will have stars in my eyes
filled with a Japanese culture with a
Japanese way of life and I think it's
very fascinating and it's gonna help me
a lot
learning the language in the long run if
you like this video please put a like
subscribe you if you haven't done so and
click on the link in the description box
there's an amazing article waiting for
you there the fourth thing that I wanted
to tell you is that if you can and want
please share with us your language
faders why you failed and if you've
started learning that language again if
you if you failed and you've given up on
that language please share the stories
because I think that it's important to
share not only our successes but also
the things that we do less well so that
others not only yourself but also others
can benefit from them see you very soon
on YouTube and as always happy language
learning
[Music]
you